ciao amico l attenti ragazzi e benvenuti
questo video sono felice oggi siamo
tornati su minecraft harcourt
poi molti di voi diranno ma non l'avevi
finto manca parkour la risposta è sì è
inutile che ti nascondi ti vedo c la
risposta è sì abbiamo finito mycup
harcourt
siccome vi è piaciuto oltre le
aspettative cioè non pensavo facesse
tutto sto successo c'è ancora più di
naufraghi ho deciso di prolungare la
serie di portare minecraft parkour 2
questa mappa qua si chiama minecraft
paradise allora qua c'è play game quindi
per andare a giocare c'è il portale la
partenza è sempre uguale devi sapere
solo in inferno vedi che sia stupido
entrate il portale per la lega aiuto
cosa vedo oh mio dio è va bene ravelli
trova quindi sono varie stanze tipo
quelle tipo cui la challenger di takeshi
scarico la prima is easy dobbiamo
arrivare alla fine c'è una torre gigante
tipo mordor baisi easy già tre sono
andate vai forte caduto ma io continuo
vai questo e vetro così scivolano al 4
no non c'è a e sono blocchi visibili a
chi l'aveva è una gara una gara non mi
frega niente stavolta non ci aiutiamo
vai va allora però è una gara ma devi
metterti le mani nel culo del fatto di
cadere indietro è veramente orribile
devi stare fermo ma basta come fai
andare così avanti ma come può essere la
maledizione maledetto chi è troppo e 6
no dai è lombare dai le mani basta che
fastidio
ok perfetto questo non è difficile
ok ma secondo me perché abbiamo fatto
tanto talmente tanto ma infatti abbiamo
giocato talmente tanto all'altra manca
artwork e questo è proprio per i bambini
quella lista difficili saranno esatto
non è cosa di saltare in quella dietro
ecco qua a destra quindi dalla normale
ma neanche questa no è impossibile
ecco abbiamo avere un tempo abbiamo già
parlato quindi niente l'ho fatta ho
saltato come ho saltato tutte le altre
volte però stavolta come fatto lo so ma
spreca mi ami ciao amico ciao allora mi
sono anche io da qua vedo la mappa da
sopra è bellissimo siamo in un cratere
gigante somma che si sia scattato un
meteorite gigante poi l'ho fatto anche
io tu sopra con di reply vieni qua ok ok
ok let's go baby let's go baby ma non è
vero
a questi sogni così di slime un'altra
volta ma per favore
saranno la nostra rovina di slide bravo
pietro vieni qua bravissimo bravissimo
come non detto scherzavo no è ok
stavo cadendo non sono caduto perfetto
attenzione l'ultimo open ci sono ci sono
ci sono bravo non capisco perché noi per
culo alternano i livelli difficili a
delle cagate allucinanti equa e ce n'è
uno che ti assicuro è veramente
difficile stavo scherzando non è facile
dai amico perché sta uscendo il sole per
bravo così ecco dovevo uscire il sole
per fartelo fare occhio quando è stato
la quale questo devo fare io adesso ti
voglio a te qual lurido maledetto o no
perché come io da pietro poi però dovevo
dare ai salta salta dai salta ci
speravano specie o del tonale sopra
pietà di me no mai
sento qualcuno che ci sono i village air
show fatta tanta vero anno quest'anno
ecco questo rally è uno dei livelli
cagata di cui parlavamo prima di seguire
il tragitto una cacata allucinante da
anzi ei ma sei un idiota maledetto vaghi
karma sei caduto in là un deficiente
meno male che c'è la vita infine no
perché se muori infatti all'inizio
quindi è vero ma meno male che c'e la
vita infinita sulla mappa perché non sto
prendendo cuori sono strumenti avrei q1
ucciso due ti avrei sgonfiato le ruote
della macchina mi sarei mangiate e 3
avremmo iniziato tutto quanto da zero
comunque abbiamo scoperto che non si può
morire bene ma quello di essenziale
finora ma ti aggrappi fa qui sopra lasci
una misura gran mandorla programmarlo
già fatta ce l'ho fatta un fenomeno
fenomeno o di un labirinto di ghiaccio
questa figata ivi diamoci dividiamoci
questi solo uno di noi arriverà alla
fine sono scherzando ti segue ho paura
che ci arrivi tu e non era nei patti e i
palchi a spendere fino a porta con sé
facciamo qualcuno non riesca ad aprire
al che ci sa fare
ma no ebano all'inizio ma porca vacca
che labirinto brutta dalla prima della
sinistra che premette tu non hai preso
la mia via che mi rende felice non si è
preso esattamente la mia porca vacca
preview è un amico siamo li volevamo
prima ok adesso queste cose giusta
questo con la giusta non sento anch'io
mi sento bravissimo non copiarmi farai
male dovrebbe mandare qua scusa ok
no aspetta non mi tornano i conti non mi
contano i torni ricordano i tanti let's
go allora maestre già lì come è
possibile se intanto da mappa gudolin
costante la mappa ti regalo un milione
di iscritti
no bravissimo nato l'ho detto perché ero
sicuro che non ci avresti fatto
ciao amici bene so fare io e mine crafar
corso rispetto di una mia storto grazie
vita by mi piace questo gioco è una
nuova attrazione di gardaland 26 ottobre
dio sei arrivato sul serio la fine beh
sì come il fatto che non è una roba che
non da stronzi di più davvero nuova via
macello però io ce l'ho fatta aspetta
che non so se devo saltata prodotto bene
ci sono ci sono state salta jump andes
club sia bravini dai non è male questa è
la stanza dei porca vacca lo sapevo
nella stanza di materiale il karma
agisce sempre equa scusami no aspetta
fermi manovra un po male ma neanche se o
ma come come hai fatto
come è possibile troppo forte come ma
non puoi arrivarci ci aveva saltato
veramente aspetta riproviamo
[Musica]
ma va a cagare va va bene a quest'ultima
parte è stata veramente difficile ve lo
giuro però o le baby ok ti sei era
difficile l'ultimo salto te lo volevo
dire niente non mi hai pagato la città
ci sono dino bloc
[Musica]
provo a suonare d'esposito queste cose
che riceveranno musichetta adeguata
[Musica]
niente o amen perfetto perfetto questo
ma ancora lindsay alla zucca la madonna
cos'è sta roba
fece una cascata gigante questo casino
ok no difficile ma io e ho sbagliato
guardare salta qua e poi sull'ultimo
come fatto sbagliare scusa ad acqua con
salto lo sbagliato prima non so come ho
fatto vieni qua ci sono delle tnt
fighter
pensate che livello strana ancora sento
il village è già fatta questi punto
salto di prima della zucca moda che poi
questa sera perché sentono di lager ma
non lo vedo si può fare qua
giusto è giusto quello che ho fatto può
essere era giusto ho fatto una cosa
incredibile né senza neanche
accorgermene
e poi ho fatto una cagata però vabbè
dettaglio barca va non c'è rischio
ok rischio dovresti fare esatto esatto
bravissimo è però da lì è un casino è
come farebbero dall'isola di sopra poi
dalle yamaha 3c porno non riesce ma sei
sicuro ora che troppo lontano ha
l'appoggio copie non ci arrivano
calcolate male di distanza e ste cose
non le puoi fare c'è troppo distante
permessi secondo me devo fare comporre
salto di trenta sull'ultima però non so
se ci arrivo sì ci ho fatto ciò può che
farvi grillo fatelo perché da lì a e
salta qua no non così 20 ragazzi procede
che possiamo concludere qui con
l'episodio di con insieme a mike appare
dai spero che il video di oggi possa
esservi piaciuto perché io concludo qua
visto che ciò la mano che sta morendo
giuro no perché tenere il tasto della
corsa e fare i salti un casino comunque
ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto ma
subito ci siamo mi piace ancora iniziare
[Musica]